Daniel Minnie t Williams kickboxing gold
on the line
the Thai Superstar tawan chai smoker Joe
not a work look at the ferocity martial
arts all sorts of disciplines at the
very highest levels
tonight
right through the city like British
[Music]
don't get involved
what is popping fam it is Monday morning
October 2nd it is 9 A.M in this brisk
brisk
um I guess Calabasas morning that's
right I forgot where I was at for a
second cool that's cool that's great
grand wonderful
what's going on everybody how you guys
doing we are live once again I am
fresh off the plane from Las Vegas
Nevada where your boy was at skank Fest
I'm sure we'll break it down more on
firing the kid but it was a phenomenal
time if you look at my Instagram post I
had reservations about going I was you
don't have to go to a gym I'm just that
confused me
um it was just a great time
um I was definitely uh hesitant about
going and uh boy am I glad that uh I
didn't post out and that I went because
um best County Festival I've ever been
part of I've been at you know all of
them but you name it your boy's been in
these comedy festivals and this is hands
down the best one
I think just the environment uh Luis
Gomez created the comics it's not so
like weird networking where people are
worried to mess up and you know because
you have big networks there and it's
like this whole kind of
you know these other kind of festivals
are just they've changed man but uh when
it comes to uh skank Fest it's all for
the fans which I think makes the the
biggest difference and boy do they have
some loyal fans and uh yeah I went into
the lion's den and um played around with
some lines in Lewis and big J and Dave
Smith and Annie Letterman and just all
these monsters Joe list is there uh
DeStefano came by Tim Dillon you just
got monsters upon monsters
and uh I brought Big Jay Schaub with me
which uh didn't make too much sense
because
you know he's the the tour manager so he
sells the whiskey sells merch well we
weren't doing that there I literally
brought him just in case I was attacked
that's how nervous I was and boy was it
we did not need I'm glad Jay came
because you know we have so much fun
together on the road but
um
we he wasn't needed the the fans were so
dope so cool and you know Gomez told me
that Dave Smith told me that big Jay
told me that but you know they say that
I'm like yeah they're nice to you guys
you know people are mean to me but uh
shout out to the skank Fest fan base man
it was it was Unreal it was Unreal I
will always do skank Fest like I said on
my Instagram post I will never not do it
I'd always uh always be an honor to be
part of it so just glad I did it man and
uh the live uh podcast that we shot with
Legion of skanks
um and finding the kid uh we should have
that file hopefully this week I would
assume that's what I'm told and then
when we up we'll upload that like a
regular episode so uh it was a fun one
it was a special one man so it was a
grand old time but so shout out to skank
Fest Louis you're the best Big Jay Dave
love you guys uh prior to that though I
uh big J shop flew into LA because we
drove from LA to Sacramento
uh because I have this whole car project
going on turning my uh Dodge Ram TRX Ram
it's really not Dodge but Ram sorry guys
uh turn it into a uh basically a demon
TRX over a thousand horsepower at the
crank
all right not the wheels be cool at the
crank uh it should be around 1100 10
50ish by the time I get it back but I
sought out this place Overkill in
Sacramento California
you know five and a half hour drive
there's a million car shops around here
but I went to them for uh this is all
they do this is what they do Josh the
the owner of Overkill has the best track
record as far as reliability maintenance
just he has an outstanding track record
so that's why I drove five and a half
hours at six a.m to seek this dude out
and uh this got a good thing going on
that we we shot all of it I gotta we
have some dope content coming but um
should be done about two weeks I would
assume but uh just wait for it because
now I got a million ideas got a dope
idea for a car show so stay posted for
that I'll be posting content all uh
during the lead up for that but that's
gonna be a fun one but uh as far as the
fight World goes I was in Vegas and
whenever you're in Vegas we couldn't
figure out why hotels were so expensive
it's because uh the most famous
person on this side of the pond that
puts on those 10 ounce gloves or uh
boxing gloves since these lighter weight
I think they're still tens could be
eights I think they're tens
um his name is Canelo Alvarez and he was
fighting Saturday night against uh Jamel
Charlo
so Vegas is popping when he's in town so
that's why the hotel prices were through
the roof he fought T-Mobile Arena
um I got done at skank Fest Saturday
night I think my last set three sets
that day I think my last day was around
seven so me and Jay rushed back to our
hotel and uh got it on his uh iPad
um I want my money back I want my money
back
um and not because of Canelo because
um and I'm a Jamel Charlo fan I like
Charlie Brothers they're great worked
with them the nice guys in the world so
talented but Jamel Charlo if you look at
Terence Crawford's tweet he got it right
like Jamal just showed up not to get
knocked out he came in not to lose he
didn't want to become a meme he didn't
want to be a highlight on canelo's you
know
um record that's that's all he so there
was no risk involved he played it safe
the whole time you know he really didn't
take many chances wasn't that active you
know when you're down eight rounds nine
rounds it's time to open up and there's
just none of that and then when they
interviewed him because this is boxing
at least I didn't get knocked out you're
like oh if that's your mentality going
in we're screwed I wish you would have
sent the press conference no one would
ever do this but I was going in here
like guys I'm gonna play it safe I'm
just not trying to get knocked out I'm
like I'm not paying for that I want my
80 back Charlo that I'm not paying for
that and this is one of the issues with
boxing and uh Nina drama Nina drama on
Twitter I think it is I think you see
him as Instagram but Nina drum put out
she goes and she got you know obviously
you're gonna rile up the boxing heads
when you do this she goes you can't tell
me that uh a main event in boxing this
year has done better than a main event
in the UFC I was coming to think of I'm
like yeah she's not especially this year
especially this year that that's the
problem with boxing and I love boxing
absolutely love boxing the sweet science
fantastic you're bat [__] crazy if you
think uh big boxing pay-per-view is
better than an MMA pay-per-view from Top
Also let's not even talk top to bottom
let's not even start with a UFC Main
Event especially the main events that
are the the main cards sorry not main
event but the main cards coming up like
these next big pay-per-views compared to
boxing
name the undercard of Francis versus
Tyson Fury
how about the undercard of Canelo and
Charlo
the co-main events they're usually
pretty decent outside that them boys
getting paid 500 bucks and you all want
to complain about our sport
it's not even CL look at the UFC it's so
juicy you got UFC 294 Mark Chev Charles
Oliveira part two to the best on the
freaking planet you also got Hamza Polo
cost on that freaking card which is
insane you have Curtis blades Almeida
coming up that's just a fight night
don't worry about that then we'll still
get more views than any free boxing
fight uh then you have Jon Jones versus
Stipe do that come on and that's in
November and then you got
um you got Leon Edwards Colby Covington
on that sick just sick sick December
16th card uh you got pantojo Brandon Roy
Val uh shopkat uh rachmanov Stephen
Wonderboy Thompson Tony Ferguson Patty
pimlet for since it Vicente Luke and Ian
Machado Gary take my Goddamn money and
you wonder why and here's where I'm
going with all this
you guys can argue on on social media oh
UFC this and boxing's better
HBO left the boxing game
Showtime left the boxing game
nobody's making any money
so we want to knock on daily you need to
pay the fighters more and you do this
yeah do the boxing blueprint how's that
worked out for anybody
trust me if if HBO Showtime these other
big networks were making money they
would be in the game of boxing
remember Dana was going to do boxing why
didn't he because the [__] show
there's nine different promotions this
guy has this belt there's all these
different weights there's no stars
it's not even close it's not even a
competition anymore it's 10-8 round for
MMA and I love I absolutely love boxing
Tyson Fury is my favorite combat sport
Athlete on the planet he's my favorite
him and Josh would be great him versus
uzik's gonna be insane but I'm I'm
talking about as far as consistent
like entertainment value it's this this
isn't a conversation I know it's going
to upset so many boxing heads out there
it's not it's not a conversation it's
not even close
so this is Aaron bronstetter said I can
come for uh and he's just retweeting he
goes uh I can confirm that Showtime will
not be continuing their boxing schedule
after 2024 following a number of
confidence calls across the pond over
the past uh I can attest at Showtime
we'd be pulling the plug unboxing after
37 years in Industry here's a full one
here if you wanna but that's so that's
an analyst for boxing rough
yeah yep yep this is pretty well known I
mean this isn't like breaking news we
knew that anybody in the Combat Sports
space knew this was happening yeah
uh and then this dude goes on and goes
top boxes asked for too much guaranteed
money on top of pay-per-view percentage
just killing the sport they need to
stick to percentage Cuts what you make
depends on what the fight Nets with
Expert Eyes on expenses of course that
way no money is lost to all the other
parties correct
when you look at these guys how much
money they're making
it's it's and then also it's like their
own promo name a main box you don't have
Zone promotion so it might be with
Showtime yeah but it's under also this
promotion it's with Canelo or it's with
a tank Davis tank has his own promo so
in their con the production the money
they're taking the line share of it so
Showtime HBO Staples in the sport
they're out I guess yeah what you have
left is Fox
they're still involved a little bit
you get the Zone which has been a train
wreck
yeah I heard it like if Showtime does do
boxing again it'll be just one-offs it
won't be like Showtime boxing
no I heard it all right yeah no I read
that if they do it again it'll just be
one-offs it's not going to be like no
there's no consistent thing yeah but and
that's that's where boxing's going you
know they're doing basically everyone
wants to give the Paul Brothers [__] but
they're they're basically doing what
they're doing where they're just going
to sell to the highest bidder so tank
Davis or Crawford even though you know
he has a deal with uh someone right now
but these guys are gonna be they're
gonna be one-offs
so you know it's gonna be tough to keep
up with it it's not good and here's why
this sucks because if you're a young
upcoming boxer there's there's not a lot
of ways to get built now there's no way
to get hype
unless you happen to luck out and get as
a combing event or the undercard on one
of these one-offs
but as far as like building the resumes
building The rosters having talent
grooming the talent that's those days
are for it's a this is terrible for
boxing
terrific all we're concerned about is
the bottom line which it is a business
end of the day this is terrible for the
young boxers
look at MMA look at just the UFC itself
you have just so you have The Ultimate
Fighter you can get you know working you
have Dan White Contender series then
there's actual UFC and then think how
many people are are on the rosters in
every weight class
it's just insane MMA in general we get
one Championship same rosters are
stacked dude stacked
there's fight nights there's Contender
series Ultimate Fighter one Championship
has a bunch of cards there's ways to do
this
there's other organizations get built up
on where people can see you in boxing
what are you gonna do
so the the Jake Paul's the Logan Paul's
of the world right so you know you look
at Francis Tyson Fury that's on ESPN
that's ESPN pay-per-view that's a
one-off
so now these guys are gonna be the
highest build bitter well what if I'm
just uh stud of a talent but I'm not
great on social media where do you go
so this is where again it's a business
but it's going to kill the sport because
now these sharks at the top which all
you know the promoters businessmen the
Sharks now they're just looking where to
make the most money but what happens
when you do that the young talent that
they go to the Wayside
they just go to the Wayside
because now it's like all right who has
the most Instagram followers who it's
not about Talent anymore it's not good
it's not good it's a big big problem man
if you're boxing that you should be
worried when HBO show time drops out
it's not good
it's not good man
and then also when you get like the the
Canelo and the uh Charlo fight not good
when one guy doesn't want to you know
he's just there for a Payday okay
I'm in the fight with you just like God
damn it and Charlie has a talent too
right it's just so much done but you
know he did take it he is he stepped in
for his brother first brother it's two
weight classes above him I get it dude
but you gotta you gotta give us
something man
because you wouldn't watch that and then
be like man I want to see that guy do it
again let's say and it's Canelo so he's
the most famous guy on this side of the
pond his argument you know he's the
biggest boxer in the world but
definitely on this side of the pond you
got your tits Anthony Joshua's cool but
on this side it's all Canelo all day
there's so many Mexicans out here right
everywhere they love even non-mexins who
doesn't love Canelo he's one of the
greatest to ever do it it made possibly
the best biggest Mexican box of all time
Julio Chavez seniors probably it's one a
one B whatever you want to do it but
you'll get canelo's resume it's it's
it's insane
so his fan base tuned in you think
they're going to jump over and watch the
Charlo fight his next fight like no hell
no they don't respect that
so it didn't do anybody any good
it's a it was such a bummer such a
bummer
such a bummer but
I'll tell you what wasn't a bummer it
was one Championship my god dude dude I
I was messaging our group text I was
like this is probably one of the best
cards I've seen especially this year you
know one of the best cards ever not uh
they're they're becoming undeniable yeah
and chatri said something that made a
lot of sense you know and he's not
feeling again they're all promoters so
they're gonna take some shots at the you
know obviously UFC's the big dog in
America so he's going to compare it to
that that's what you want to do so he
just said the difference and one of the
reasons why one Championship is so
entertaining is because we have
world-class Strikers
because then when the guy's getting he
had a good point because when guys get
to the UFC they're not known for their
strike in their division one wrestlers
and then they learn to strike and then
they're 3-04 and all the UFC signs them
they're learning to strike when they get
to the UFC he goes if you look how many
world champions we've had in Striking
crossover you can come over to one
Championship you know there's probably a
hundred you see there's maybe four five
he's like so we look for the by the time
they come to us they have all these
credentials in regards to striking so
you get the best Elite Strikers versus
the best Elite when the UFC this guy
might be getting decent at this this
guy's decent lit you know so he had a
good point there but my God and how good
is stamp fair tax and the story leaned
up to us when they post Angela Lee
retiring thank God and when she had to
go tell Sam she's like hey this is going
to be for the legit Bell yeah oh my God
and stamps like I'm gonna try my best
I'm gonna try my best I'm crying yeah
yeah she did it to him so he too she was
before like they didn't know they that
was like a regular what like interim
maybe but she's like no this is they
both cried they both love Angela he's
the best yeah the best absolute best
shot to her stamp like so and I keep
telling you guys this if you get a
chance to watch stamp Fair attacks you
think she's just big you know in the
Asian market she is a bona fide
Superstar out her out here
I I mean I'm trying to think as far as
America goes I mean she's big man big
big I don't care what organization
you're talking about it'd be tough to
find someone bigger than stamp Fair text
and also skill-wise again to compare it
to to these other leagues you know they
might have some wrestling background
they might be oh a jiu jitsu gold medal
or something like that but stamps
credentials filthy
in her walk out she's just a unique
character man her walk I when I when I
saw in person walk I'm like oh she's
about to get beat up you're dancing
around doing these Tick Tock dances
she's smiling and this dance for this
world championship was the best one yet
full-blown
I mean NSYNC Vibe bye bye bye just doing
the whole thing I'm like how does this
grow and then when she gets that cage
it's on
she's such a badass dude
she's such a badass they got a superstar
there they got a straight up Superstar I
didn't realize but so I guess stamp has
been doing it since she was like a
little kid have you seen the video yeah
it's so crazy crazy like a little little
time yeah tiny little kid and then our
girl uh Daniel Kelly if you haven't seen
the one-on-one with Daniel Kelly she's
great Philadelphia's finest her thing
and Jessica Khan is a bona fide world
champion like gee Jitsu does all the big
tournaments ADCC uh International Brazil
and Jitsu Federation she does all that
stuff and she does well on that uh she's
a gold medalist she's a badass Dana
Kelly's not Daniel Kelly is a
professional Jiu Jitsu player and
doesn't have that same pedigree so for
her it was a big deal to go in there and
and beat her
and she did it yep she did she looked
damn good too she looked really good
doing it
won a girl lost that was a bummer she's
way better than I thought I thought for
sure she would get destroyed yeah but
she's really good she's fun to watch
John lineker just Savage of all the
cards I thought for sure that would be
the TKO or KO and that's the the one
decision out of all the fights it's so
freaking crazy
get because when you tune into it you
get you get uh Maurice and Blake Cooper
TKO first round then you get Muay Thai
and you get KO uh punch head kick in the
third round early and third round then
you get heavyweight TKO uh his doctor
stoppage but still is entertaining and
then you get a KO in the third round you
had TKO uh with three knockdowns there's
Muay Thai and then John lineker you're
like this is definitely yeah I thought
first decision and then uh Wonder Girl
lost again TKO Daniel Kelly of Jiu Jitsu
match submission grappling it was
entertaining as [__]
um shout out to Daniel Kelly there and
then you get uh women's strawweight Muay
Thai uh fight uh TKO punches and elbows
third round and then of course your main
event stamp fear attacks
um becomes the atom weight world
champion
get one Championship just does it right
man does it right they had one little
hiccup and Dana they didn't capitalized
on it had one little hiccup yeah but
that's it these promos didn't take the
stab it's not a big deal
and when I saw him like oh man what one
Championship do all they did is when
Daniel Kelly's walking out they're
showing the one Championship thing and
this dude like walks out sipping a big
golf just a big golf yeah he's like
sipping like a tight holding some coffee
yeah that guy just went down the road
he's like whoa wrong wrong uh wrong way
my bad and then Dana tweeted out
Espanola has taken over the production
for one FC that was super funny it's
funny yeah it's harmless
and then he went in on he went in on him
for sure which we don't need to go into
him and Espinoza hate each other
just Rich dudes arguing about rich [__]
you're like okay yeah
it's a bummer they're both I feel like
they can help each other out
spinos is weak and smart I mean of
course he made a freaking son of a damn
company yeah yeah
what else you got bud uh so over the
weekend also Cedric dumbe who was like a
Glory Kickboxing Champion he's a big big
Prospect yeah huge Prospect undefeated
in MMA so far uh he came out with a bed
during the walkout this is the pfl and
it says like uh Jordan his opponent is
gonna go to sleep or something like that
now and what's intro about this is the
UFC passed on him yeah I remember this
too yeah and everyone's like really you
sure and pfl was like we'll take him and
then this dude is a Savage yeah but this
is but this is great for pfl it's
exactly what you need that's what
Bellator needed it's these guys that
aren't already you know they have all
the miles on them from the UFC and then
come over the pfl or then come over to
Bellator like that's what one
Championship does they do great they
build their own fighters their own
Superstars across the board with us Muay
Thai Jiu Jitsu they have Superstars
Mikey mushumeshi competes this weekend
against Aoki I gave Mass they're doing
their own thing it's just not a runoff
of the UFC former UFC yet they don't do
that they build their own stuff so for
pfl this is going to be their biggest
challenge and getting this guy thank God
for pfl the UFC you know turned it down
because he's a killer yeah
The Knockout was bad too yeah nine
seconds like that's like what a debut
yeah um yeah so and he brought a bed he
brought a bed beforehand his opponent's
gonna go to sleep if you're fighting
like what the hell I know dude
all right well shout out to Cedric
I mean did we kind of cover this a
little bit no right not yet no okay so
we were talking before the show so Tyson
Fury apparently has signed a contract to
fight Alexander usick maybe like a month
or two after
but yeah right now it looks like
December 23rd even if it was in January
yeah that's crazy here's the here's the
thing October 28th yeah and that's for
sure happened October 28th is happening
for him to schedule a fight against his
toughest opponent in usig by far as
toughest opponent using is a bad man
Stephen A Smith says the baddest man
this dude has never lost in anything
including Checkers this dude is a
problem I think two-time gold medalist
in the Olympics Ukrainian never lost as
a pro he's the to me damn near the
perfect size
um
mm-hmm
yeah look at this Olympic Games gold
European championships Gold World Cup
you got silver
that heavyweight just such a monster
yeah he's such a Savage if you watch his
uh Anthony Joshua fights he he's a
nightmare nightmare he he's the one guy
that you know you talk about Joshua you
talk about any of these guys
um any of them against Tyson I always I
Tyson all day I don't care who it is
Tyson all day usick is the one where
you're like
he's a problem
is a problem because I you know I think
Tyson has an advantage over Joshua
Wilder any of the big boys any of the
big boys he has an advantage over he's
just technically so much better so much
elusive can fight forward backwards can
do it all technical wise he's as good as
they get the one heavyweight who's
better technically than uh Fury is USIC
he's a Savage he's a Savage that being
said this is the takeaway from them
announcing
weeks prior to him fighting Francine
Gano they think this is going to be the
easiest fight of Tyson Fury's career for
them to go
beyon fight October 28th yeah yeah we're
fine let's do it in December yeah but
usick's gonna be your toughest matchup I
know this thing over here this Francis
guy not a big deal we're gonna do this
it's so insulting if you're Francis in
Ghana's camp
they're just going this is going to be a
cakewalk
and we're going to use that to prepare
for us we're just going to stay in Camp
we're not worried about getting cut
we're not worried about taking any
damage this fight's gonna be so easy
we're gonna schedule the biggest fight
of Tyson Fury's career a few weeks after
that is the biggest Fu I've ever seen in
Combat Sports
Lee Francis I don't know what the
minimum medical suspension boxing but I
really don't understand how Tyson can
fight in December after what's going to
happen on 10 28. oh I do that's basy
Tyson going we're not worried in any
faster but this is a sideshow to me to
Francis this is as real as gets to
Tyson's like yeah make that money I'm
embarrassed this dude and when then
we'll just well I'll take a day off
maybe go to the pub hang out with my
wife shoot a shoot a reality show and
then we'll just jump in and camp and
fight usick
you this is the biggest Flex I've ever
this is the biggest disrespect for a big
fight like this that I've ever this is
the biggest disrespect in Combat Sports
history him just going yeah I have a
huge fight on the 28th against this uh
UFC guy but give me usick in December
they could have done this in March
April May even if he for Tyson the whole
thing if the boxing heads were like how
you gonna fight Francis they hate this
right this is a circus you're gonna
fight Francis usick is out there you
keep you know you're worried about usick
you're you're trying to shy away from
fighting music and he goes no no so to
get all the boxing off his back is watch
this I'll fight Francis make all the
money right and see me the easiest paid
in my life and then also with negotiate
the USIC fight shut your mouth
so the Box committee is like oh all
right I see what you did there
because
the fury using fight is the only fight
that's the only fighting heavyweight
boxing that we need to see that this is
the fight
they could have done it in July of 2024
they get done in August even if he said
you know what I'm gonna fight Francis
this December next December I'll fight
usick we would have went yay but this
dude in his Camp is so sure that this is
gonna be a cake walk these fools
scheduled it weeks later this is the
biggest disrespect I've ever seen at
this high level it's so effed up
there doesn't need to be any trash talk
before the thing all I need to go is if
I'm Francis is what I do before every
single uh like all the the pre-fight
smack talk as soon as you go friend tell
you about how do you feel about this
fire go using December 12th that's how I
feel about it I just promote that that's
all I would do hey are you worried about
Francis and what he's gonna bring he's a
Knockouts uh good question usig check
this out whatever it is ESPN paybrew
December 14th see you guys there hey
how's Camp going fantastic hey make sure
you check out usig December 16th live on
Showtime
that's all you need to say there's
[Music]
um
no respect for Francis if I'm Francis
I'm like oh wow a you're like you're
pissed B you're a little bit like huh he
really doesn't respond mental games oh
you're really like oh damn this this
fool but the toughest fight of his
career
weeks after scheduling to fight me
so I'm Tyson we don't need any witty
comebacks you don't need to make fun of
them or or check out my love handles get
a grip none of that none hey are you
worried about France power great
question make sure you check out usick
and me fighting December 24th live on
only fans or whatever the hell it's
gonna be like literally just that that's
all you need to know
there's zero respect there I saw I went
oh what a flex dude
though that is the best
[__] talking I've ever seen and he
didn't have to do it
he's called up he's going hey uh yeah
just announced usick when you want to
fight him uh what do we win uh do it in
December
Savage dude yeah
insane I'm a little worried if I'm
Phantom like oh man that's he really
thinks me that easy yeah yeah they do
they're not taking it serious at all
he's using you
as basically live sparring before he
fights usick that's how much respect he
has
could now on the other side of that if
I'm Francis
all right
okay this is good he's not taking this
serious and when you hit as hard as
Francis does again can he sit back and
dance and pick Fury apart absolutely not
but I don't care who you are there's no
man walking this planet
maybe Roy Nelson is prime but there's no
man walking this planet who can take a
flush right or left hook from Francis
inganu and wake up it's not gonna happen
so Francis has that nuke in his he has
that freaking African nuke in the back
of his pocket
so if Tice and that's the only way
France is going to win Tyson has to just
maybe glance at the clock in one
millisecond and that that right hand
comes through a left hand comes through
and this thing's over it's the biggest
upset in Combat Sports history
the Connor and Floyd that was not a
possibility it's just not at that weight
class there's it's not that one shot not
if I don't again I can't emphasize
enough if you're France ganu if you're
using IF Francis hits you flush in the
face the night is over
so if so this kind of this kind of puts
more chips into Francis Corner going all
right all right because we're all in
France is using this as a tuna so
Francis this is a glorified sparring
match okay
now remember we have a chance you should
be worried if they're doing the
countdowns and Tyson's saying how much
he respects you and it's gonna be the
toughest fight then he's like oh damn
I'm getting the a version of Tyson we
don't have a shot which that's a fact
but if we get just a b version of France
or Tyson well they okay
not bad
not bad the NFL scene is going strong
all right the NFL is here baby Jetson
looked terrible Jets didn't look
terrible
not at all I still didn't win but still
uh I'll tell you this right now if that
NFL broadcast mentions Taylor Swift one
more time I'm never watching the NFL
again I'll tell you that right now and I
want Taylor Swift I'm a Swifty I respect
her she's talented
if you mentioned her one more time I'm
never watching your product again I know
you guys don't care because you're the
biggest league in the world but I'm just
saying don't make me do it if you
mentioned Taylor Swift one more goddamn
time I'm gonna just freak out
that being said the NFL is here and my
Broncos what's up we look like the worst
team in the league last week we we Dr
they dropped 70 points on us okay and
then we played the Chicago Bears I went
well this is the worst match of all time
and they were looking like the worst
team in the league besides the
Pittsburgh Steelers that's a whole
nother story they look atrocious but my
Broncos came back baby what's up what's
up daddy my Broncos came back and look
at the stats you all want to hate on
Russell Wilson but he looked at his
numbers compared to Patrick Mahomes suck
it so if you're an NFL fan or college
fan how about my Buffs only lost by
seven not terrible here's why I'm not
mad that they've lost two in a row I
wish they won but we've already won this
season now we play ASU next weekend
we're going to beat the living breaks
off of them but then we play UCLA at
UCLA I need them to lose two games so
Daddy can't afford tickets for his
family because before when when they
were 3-0 I looked at tickets hey kids we
ain't going they lose two games hey kids
it's looking good
they beat USU we're still good they lose
the issue we definitely going
so it's a good thing dude it's a good
thing is all I'm saying so if you like
to watch football and make Bank Bros so
you can buy tickets for your kids you
can't afford like UCLA versus CU you can
go to DraftKings bet five bucks on any
game this week to score 200 instantly in
bonus bets and DraftKings isn't stopping
there all customers can take advantage
of a sweeter offer every game day this
October it's Halloween season baby it's
Halloween season get in on the game day
greatness download the DraftKings
Sportsbook app now use the code shop
show that's Schaub show new customers
can score 200 instantly in bonus bets
when you bet five on the NFL that's
coach shop show only on draftking
Sportsbook an official Sportsman partner
of the NFL the crown is yours
can you bet on how many times I
mentioned Taylor Swift there has to be
an over under guarantee it I have to
read that don't I yeah I'd rather you
say Taylor Swift than read this right
now gambling problem call 1-800 Gambler
or visit
www.1800 gambler.net in New York call
8778 Hope and why or text Hope and why
that's 467-369 in Connecticut God bless
you help is available for problem
gambling call
888-789-777 or just get out of
Connecticut or visit
ccpg.org please play responsibly on
behalf of Boot Hill Casino Resort Kansas
licensee partner Golden Nugget Lake
Charles la
21 plus age varies by jurisdiction void
in Ontario bonus bets expire 168 hours
after issuance see
sportsbook.draftkings.com football terms
for eligibility and deposit restrictions
terms and responsible gaming resources
if you're still listening
Taylor Swift don't say it ever again
DraftKings promo code Shop show
oh I this is one of my favorites I met
the owner of sheath at the skank Fest I
mean that guy really hit across me and
him are buddies now this is my dude
these are the best underwear you've got
to send me some dude the ones I have
have stains in them so listen I'm happy
to welcome uh sheath to the shop show
sheath underwear baby sheath underwear
makes the most comfortable briefs I've
ever worn this is no BS these are the
best undies that will ever touch your
thick body every time you hear my voice
or you see this brutal face I'm in Chief
boxer briefs baby they're stretchy
fabric is made of moisture I think it's
made of angel wings I don't know talk to
them about it they're comfortable and
it's comfortable right in the best
places all right after trying sheath you
can never go back to those old tired
brands that your dad used to wear it had
peepee stains in the front I love the
Dual pouches they keep your man part
separated kind of dude depends where
you're at right sheath uses materials
like bamboo and mess for even more cool
and comfort all right so go to
sheathunderwear.com that's
s-h-e-a-t-h-underwear.com use the code
shop schab and you get 20 off the best
undies made of angel wings all right
that sheath underwear dot com today use
the promo code Shob for 20 off
oh we ate messing around
a little while ago I had this crazy idea
on to sell stuff uh like merch for my
shows and all the podcasts and I didn't
know where to get started and then
somebody said why don't you go to
Shopify I went whoa what Shopify is the
Commerce platform revolutionizing
millions of businesses worldwide whether
you're a garage entrepreneur or IPO
ready Shopify is the only tool you need
to start and run and grow your business
without the struggle don't be struggle
City be Shopify City Shopify puts you in
control of every sales channel so
whether you're selling satin sheets from
shopify's in-person POS system or
offering organic olive oil on shopify's
all-in-one e-commerce platform we got
you covered man and once you've reached
your audience Shopify has the internet's
best converting checkout to help you
turn them from browsers to buyers all
right Shopify Powers 10 of all
e-commerce in the US and Shopify is
truly a global Force Plus shopify's
Award winning help is there to support
you every step of the way this is a
possibility powered by Shopify all you
gotta do when you sign up for a one
dollar per month trial period at
shopify.com all lowercase schab small
letters lowercase go to shopify.com to
take your business to the next level
today shopify.com
now let's get back to the goddamn
program
alrighty so unfortunately for Mark hunt
he was trying to sue the UFC obviously
because of his Brock Lesnar fight he
said they were you know
there they knew that Brock was going to
test positive and they still let the
fight go whatever but uh he lost that
fight yep and Dana White says that he's
gonna have to pay some lawyer fees now
listen Mark Khan has lost so many
lawsuits against us insane he's a bit of
a delusional guy he's gonna have to face
some legal phase and their their lawyers
are not cheap dude I can't imagine doing
that that's gonna be tough and this is
just kind of funny with the chill
sudden's take on it was just basically
like dude you love you saw what Brock
looks like you know he's on stuff so
it's kind of a silly that's what's tough
like to just kind of piggyback on jail
there
um
the issue is is clearly we all know
Brock was on I mean come on and you but
then you remember it's not like
there's no paper record of this you
signed the contract we all know and you
said that like when I thought Levar
Johnson I pleaded to the UFC it doesn't
matter the end of the day I was like
he's on steroids dude and Dan's like nah
we'll see I'm like I'm telling you
finished fifth in Olympia right now look
at him but I signed a contract and I
went out there and beat them brakes off
shout out to Lamar Johnson didn't want
to fight yeah want to grab you just take
down after take down not fun for the
fans but your boy got paid so the
problem there is is I knew he was on
stuff and I still signed the contract
that's the problem for Mark hunt yeah so
if he was like nah nah I'm not fighting
he's on steroids I'm not signing a
contract and they force him to fight
then you might have some there but it's
tough
so jail goes on say you didn't need a
drug test or no Lesnar was on steroids
or was on steroids now or on steroids
next week or on steroids in college just
look at him you can take one look at him
you meet the guy who's going to the
carnival he wants to yell at the worker
afterwards you saw the ride and he
bought a ticket because if you're gonna
go on a carnival ride you know there's a
chance I think it's going to break down
and something could happen it says Mark
isn't wrong for doing this I'm just
bringing a point but Mark doesn't get to
throw on a Mr surprise face when uh a
guy he knows is using steroids test
positive for steroids agree yeah like
it's just part of the game man
but I think he has so much kind of anger
towards UFC this is one angle and it's
just a bad Hill to die on
uh so this is kind of related to this in
a little way uh Josh Thompson recently
said that when Nate Diaz Nate has popped
like many years ago for some sort of
thing that was in his supplements uh and
I guess from what Josh Thompson is
saying that the UFC knew that he popped
and they they're like hey just fight
anyways right we'll we'll handle it
later we'll talk about it later and Nate
said no I'm gonna deal with it right now
was this during The Saturdays yeah the
early Saturdays still you saw today yeah
so he says when I when I'm looking at
Leslie I mean
uh okay here we go so this is Joshua
look at this way this is the thing look
what they were trying to do with the
ideas he tested positive and they were
like you know what we'll get all sort
out after Nate said Fu when you sort out
now that means they knew that Nate
tested and they were still gonna let him
fight so I would not say that they have
not tried to do that or would not do
that
yeah yeah it's the fight business
and and also you sought as an employee
of the UFC that's always a weird thing
yeah yeah they could control the
narrative there dude it's like WWE
testing when you find out a guy tests
hot you're like oh man they hate that
guy
yeah he is you know yeah
he says why I'm looking at last night I
mean I'm just thinking to myself that
was early and you said I don't know I
don't want to say that they knew but oh
we all knew I mean come on hey and I
don't give a [__] Josh
uh which I'd only give you the case is
that they tried to have Nate still fight
and we'll deal with after I know people
in Nate's Camp said that they even tried
to offer money that's crazy they tried
to like we'll take care of it afterwards
no big deal it's right just a
misunderstanding wheat's a little
different uh no it wasn't wheat it was a
it's just something in his supplement
like maybe like you know those sarms
yeah that kind of stuff oh was it weed
no no it was something well that's
alarming I figured you test it out for
weed and they're like hey let's just not
get this announce and mess with the
Pay-Per-View buys but when it's uh
failed for something else that's a
little dicey they were like hey just be
quiet and hear some money
yeah yeah yeah but who knows if it's
actually true everybody loves hot dogs
you find out how they're made everyone
loves fighting to you look at the
underbelly
alrighty so also about testing Logan
Paul he said for sure that Vada will be
drug testing him and Dylan danis
yeah Dylan had some tweets about this
about the drug testing I just saw him
saying like he's done with everything
he's like I'm out with him no I bet he's
not out again if he is out let's even
create a world of problems for of course
he should because then you have Mike
Perry and that it's a very tough fight
for Logan
like what who's he who's he's been
competing against like I can't emphasize
enough don't fight Mike Perry you're not
gonna beat Mike Perry
even though you might think your foot
works better your jet take all that out
this kid is a dog a dog he breaks dudes
he broke Luke rockhold's teeth Logan
so this is worst case for Logan because
obviously Dylan's done his thing
building up the fight it's obviously you
know across the line a little bit so now
there's all these lawsuits so then Dylan
might have to pull out
all that being said we all want to see
him fight Dylan and then insert Mike
Perry which nobody's talking about but
is a much much different fight this is
this would be worst case scenario for
Logan I bet if Logan do it again I bet
he wouldn't have signed Dylan now
Dylan's done his job he's kind of the
the America's sweetheart now and kind of
helped his career as far as that goes
not get so much hate because there's
more hate for Logan there's Dylan him
doing his thing everyone's like yeah get
him and then Dylan's is you know baby
face now but if he doesn't fight
then insert my Perry and it's a [__]
nightmare so for Logan if someone's like
hey this kid's gonna trash her fiance
they're gonna build up all he's gonna
build a fight card but you're not going
to fight him you're actually going to
fight Mike Perry he like oh my God
that's a terrible deal
here he has money
a little awful deal so my my fiance is
gonna get [__] shamed through the roof
and then I can't even punch the guy in
the face no no not only can he not punch
him in the face but the guy you're gonna
try punching the face his name is Mike
Perry who's that exhibit a he broke Luke
rockhold's teeth
that's what you're dealing with
he actually thinks you guys are [__]
because you have gloves on what yeah he
likes to do it bare knuckle it's a
nightmare dude
worst case scenario for Logan
yeah
all right next one Stephen Thompson so
you know there is like controversy about
him not getting paid even though he made
weight should have been still haven't
figured it out but uh so Stephen
Thompson did say that he believes that
the UFC will pay him after his fight
with shotkot and just give him like a
pay bump you know basically a pay bump
is assuming that he said he's I guess
his people are talking but then Dana
White like someone said you know someone
asked that at a post fight press
conference for the contender series and
Dan's like if someone said it if Steven
said it then I guess it must be true so
who knows oh that's not good I wonder if
Davis hasn't checked that box yeah he's
like yeah I guess if that's what Mick
told him but I'm not aware of that
hopefully he gets paid though
he'll get paid the problem is is
you know he wants somebody ranked ahead
of him and the UFC went say less except
oh you'll fight anybody ranked ahead of
you how about the guy who's just one
ahead of you he's like wait wait what
it's got and it's a terrible matchup for
you
it's a little bit of a discipline thing
oh you don't want to fight that guy
but you do want to get ranked ahead of
you here's shavkot
he's a nightmare
yeah I mean so down that's so cool that
he's down to freaking fight shotgun
though oh it's insane Wonder Boy ain't
scared nobody yeah
all right this is a pretty badass fight
Sonia dong so it's in the works at least
for December fine night
yeah Peter John you know for whatever
reason once he lost his sugar it's kind
of gone it's been a tough
tough road for him yeah so on your dong
is gonna be a handful for him it's a
it's a hard fight for sure yeah for both
guys but I'm
um early odds for Me song I got song too
yeah
what a surprise
dude I'm Korean he's like yeah I know
but all right all right hey man I know
yeah you're kind of you're kind of right
you're kind of right now yeah all right
so this was just a
a weird thing so Tim Kennedy he posts he
puts it on his ex now
he goes robbery anniversity and the end
of my fight career dear Nevada NAC uh if
the combatant fails or refuses to resume
competing when the bell sounds referee
shall award a decision of TKO this is
when he fought you all Romero remember
they had school mess up thing it's
called stool gate for the kids out there
no cap yeah so he said referee obviously
John McCarthy was a referee so John had
this huge post about it and John was the
ref yeah uh oh Big John's a beast he put
Tim you're an amazing person I truly
wish the very best life has to offer you
both you and your family perhaps I could
have done something differently during
your fight wish I had the forethought to
Envision this exact situation before it
ever occurred and that way I may have
handled it differently but you are not
stating facts about what really happened
Joel was told to stay seated by the uh
Nevada State athletic commission
inspector the truth is the cut man hired
and paid for by the UFC did not re-enter
the cage when summoned to do so and that
is what held up the start of the third
round so you're out of your goddamn mind
out of that yeah uh it is not you all's
fault that this occurred and the cutman
is not part of Yolo's official Corner
dumbass I also added that in language
Bears did not help as well obviously
it's ridiculous to penalize a person
when they are not at fault and this is
what there were no point deductions nor
DQ was it completely fair to you no I
don't believe it was but there are times
when there is no perfect solution in the
moment you're definitely lost I hope
that the very best for you and all that
you do
Big John if you added a little so I I
put a little more flavor a little flavor
that was the context Big John was gonna
he but I hope the very best for you and
all that you do quit crying Big John
I mean us yeah
there's a million things that go on
there yeah so our boy Matt Steamroller
for vola posted this recently on his
Instagram so he's been the underdog and
um the majority of his last fights and
he destroys everybody right I know so
this says his next opponent it's a tough
fight it is of course it's a very tough
fight when I saw him like oh
but so he's uh Denise is a minus 400 and
then football is plus 330 which is
pretty big but then forever to put this
this picture right here
Underdog and all his last three fights
so against Drew Dober he's a you know
plus 285 which in mma's huge yeah uh
November 12th UFC 281 he was a plus 105.
that's basically even money MMA and then
against Valdez who's a plus 110. not
terrible but this fight for him to be a
plus 400 that's that's insulting it's a
very tough fight now you know we're
First Team all Steamroller here I think
he's gonna win I don't like to fight for
him but I do believe he can get it done
same I think people are sleeping on his
knockout power and his caption is hit
her to love it the Underdog's on top
because he's always been on top as an
underdog so far yep in the last three
UFC just ain't doing him any favors I
mean come on man he's a great dude help
him out help him out I do so I mean can
we get a favorable [__] matchup
speaking of matchups speaking matchups
don't listen to my picks and that's why
I partnered up with fantasy Guru if
you've been playing fantasy football if
you've been betting on the NFL or the
UFC or whatever League you're betting on
take the expert's advice that's why I
partnership with fancy Guru because they
take all the guesswork out because these
dudes are experts in the field of
betting don't listen to my stupid picks
listen to real experts they're gonna
work hand in hand with DraftKings so you
can make a more informed pick for your
shot over one million dollar top prize
every Sunday on DraftKings all right the
experts are gonna do all the work for
you all you got to do is join fancy Guru
go to fancy guru.com use the code shop
you get 20 off all the site so you get
expert picks think about it you sign up
for that small fee and you get 20 off
using the code shop right but then you
make more Bank batting it's brilliant
you want to make Bank bro use the
experts don't listen to me or people
like me on you YouTube we don't know
what the hell we're talking about these
are legit experts they're not biased
like me they didn't train with certain
guys or have a favorite guy or because
he has a big wiener they always pick him
these are experts all right fancy
guru.com promo code shop you're welcome
this episode of the shop show is also
brought to you by the best Kratom on
planet Earth the only brand that I trust
to put in this sweet sweet thick body of
mine we talk about happy hippo that's
right they have gummies they have
powders they have uh instant shots which
I always take the energy shots right
here the creative energy shots this is
the Cherry Pom-Pom for Pomegranate they
have the highly concentrated shots then
they have their K dips holler you ever
heard of Kratom K dips never well happy
hippo did it this is Wintergreen of
Razzle Dazzle I prefer the winter green
these are Kratom extract pouches
nicotine free tobacco-free just best
Kratom on the planet in pouch form
holler if you love all this stuff you
want to try Kratom you want to get into
it have fun it's a fun Old Road to go
down but you gotta use happy hippo go to
happyhippo.com promo code is thick 23
that's thick with three C's 23 you save
20 off everything I told you about
gummies powders it's kind of gun
straight shots energy shots the K dips
we got it all don't go anywhere else
just go to happyhippo.com promo code
thick23 let's get back to the freaking
program chin alrighty
oh this is kind of cool Paul Felder
uh so rumors are he will be returning to
fight at UFC 300. God who would they
give him I don't know
no idea but I mean the fact that he's
coming back he has like such a great job
as a I know I know but he said uh the
crazy zombie zombie inspired him yeah
now if you think you're gonna send off
zombie dude that's gonna be tough to
duplicate
that's gonna have to be very tough and
it happened remember you showed me the
video like Jay Park yeah a huge area
where they're seeing zombies yeah nuts
but yeah Chef Paul Felder yeah
all right um Jared Gordon posted this
that uh since he's fighting at 295 which
remember we looked at the ticket prices
and they're insane it was like 700 bucks
or something was the minimum and 112 or
something Max so Jordan Gordon posted
something on either Twitter or his
Instagram showing that he paid 22 000
roughly 22 000 for his tickets for his
family and friends oh so he's fighting
for free
and then uh people were freaked out
because obviously that's hey friends and
family
the five tickets for that are two
thousand each how about you chip in a
little bit who knows seven of you fox
for the twelve hundred dollars a ticket
how about you chip in a little bit the
five at six hundred that's acceptable a
little bit but God dog also how hey UFC
could you give them a promo code for 10
off so this is what the promo that's why
you see 600. I think the lowest was like
seven or eight so this is with the
discount and he was getting UFC props to
he's like yeah they gave me shout out to
UFC man only twenty two thousand dollars
to bring my family that's how crazy we
are
yeah so these are discount tickets I got
through UFC for my fight at Mass Square
Garden for some family and friends UFC
has some loyal fans to be selling out in
the arena close twenty thousand some odd
seats that price is higher than these
love you all thanks UFC
John Jared 22 000 bro and then he was
upset because buddy elbow posted it and
he thought they were talking smack or
something he goes what the f is this
that's how Bloody elbow does what was
okay so they did just post what but I'm
I'm with Buddy elbow on this little bit
I'm not looking at going hell yeah dude
you got hooked up I'm with bloody elbow
like that but I'm 100 with bloody elbow
how all of us are like okay that's
actually a good deal no no this guy is
in a fist fight in Mass Square Garden
and he has to pay 22
000 in tickets in order for his family
to watch him compete he is an employee
well subcontract employee of the UFC
this guy's not making Conor McGregor uh
Izzy Sean Strickland style money here
22 000 is all the money in the world
yeah
and bloody elbow goes this story is the
prices no one twisted your words or
misrepresented you no one said you were
ungrateful you shared it publicly the
price is just very high and then
Jared Gordon says okay thanks for
clarifying yeah if I'm with bloodyella
hey hey this isn't normal everybody
this is not good that a fighter has to
put 22 000 out of his own money so his
family can watch him fight this isn't a
flex this is not good
that is insane I would just I can't
imagine if I go just watch it at home
though right because I'm not making a
million bucks email's making a million
to spend 22 000 on tickets I can't
imagine that
yeah hopefully in New York so that means
really you got to make about 44 000 just
to cover that
hopefully they're all pitched in though
they did it
you know
um Family Works uh so this is Zhang
Whaley on Instagram they also need
spending money Jared so it's gonna be
more like 25 000 total because then you
just pay for everything they need snacks
parking ain't cheapy oh my God he's paid
for parking mass square gun parking it's
gonna be more like 30 grand total
and then we can't drive back with all
this traffic so you need to book a room
there math Square Garden now
and we get hungry we need room service
it's gonna be about forty seven thousand
dollars
what's this uh Zhang Whaley I don't know
where this might be at the pi but so
Zane Whaley actually picked up Shaq he's
like what 300 almost 400 pounds uh yeah
he's seven four
so she picked him up for a little bit
there she'll pick them up for a very hot
second think about it she's so tiny okay
I hate this video
it went a little bit viral so that's
interesting this I figured she like
picked them up and like spun them around
I mean I think she probably could she
did this
yeah she went like this I was like whoa
whoa
so so this video I don't know what which
fight this is from but this is John Adam
and Joe Rogan getting too excited and
pushing him and then so John annik and
freak MMA posted this
[Laughter]
[Music]
but when you're excited I do the same
[__] too that's hilarious yeah super
funny oh
um
oh this is just okay so Dylan Downes is
sparring with Alex behano and then when
I looked at their height difference as
at least when they're sparring they're
not too different but Alex is definitely
bending down a lot yeah so I didn't
realize that still has shoes on too
there oh yeah you're right and Alex is
Barefoot yeah we're all out of uh
current events huh
this is where I go to it's all real
quick Dylan Downs check out him sweating
here
so this is where I go towards like the I
get the fun stuff the fun stuff yeah and
this is Dana White posting again about
his new his body his figure he looks
great he's Jack dude
uh where's yusato though I'm with Nina
on this let's get used out of there he
looks fantastic he does especially for
his age I'm not sure how is he in his
50s or hell yeah fifth three 56 damn
near 60 bro no wait oh dude he's he's
him and Rogan the same age 55.
I think Rogue is 56.
um you wanna do some fan questions
uh fan questions sure all right
so this is one that we missed last week
because we had back to back to back
shows we didn't know I did three on
Monday I know it was crazy
so from Power structure any chance we'll
see Bryce Mitchell Eddie Bravo and Sam
Sam Tripoli on a Calabasas fight
companion wow
that's a great idea my man yeah uh next
big pay-per-view October 21st Michael of
Charles Oliveira I'll be doing one with
Rogan
but then we have two major ones November
December
Eddie and Sam are here I would just have
flying Bryce Mitchell that's a brilliant
idea that's a yeah and I wouldn't have
to do any talking
you know they they got their black belts
all obviously always got black belts in
Jiu Jitsu except for Sam but when it
comes to conspiracy I am a one stripe
white they're all black belts so I'll
just sit back and go
that's a great idea
cool we're gonna try to make that happen
matter of fact hell yeah
uh so this is from
Prince Vegeta Sun uh who will be the
first person to lose their belt in 2024
there's just a few
I don't know why Jamal Hill's still
there oh because it's not taking yet
uh man that's a good question
uh not Alexa
Pizza
yep I think waylay or depending what
matchups they give Sean Strickland or
Leon Edwards I think it's made a lot of
movement with the belts Leon Edwards had
some tough fights we'll see with Colby
uh if Muhammad gets a chance I think he
could get it done which Strickland
depends what they want to do uh if
hamzat wins the the Hamza Strickland
fights very tough fight for Strickland
um with Tatiana Suarez versus wayle I
think Tatiana eats her alive
um so there's some tough ones pentosia
you know that Moreno fight was super
close that could go either way so
there's gonna be a lot of
shifting of the belts the only one
that's not going to shift is uh at
heavyweight and uh vokunov's got
featherweight unless he gives up the
belt
alrighty
uh so Ryan Sutherland does pfl and one
Championship explode more in popularity
in the next couple of years if so what
effect will that have on the UFC none I
think the UFC is the Coca-Cola of you
know of fighting so it's or the kleenex
of tissue paper so the the
it's in America it's a it's a one-man
race or one brand race but when it comes
to International one championship's
doing the this is why I messed with one
Championship they're doing their own
thing they're not a byproduct of the UFC
like every other league every other
league takes shots at Dana and we're
gonna do this and they're just a real
really shitty virgin in the UFC whether
it's the owners of The League trying to
be all Brash like Dana even though they
don't have 400 million in the bank from
fighting you know that it's everyone
tries to mimic and be a real crappy
version of the UFC and it's just it's
not good one Championship is in their
own lane doing their own thing with
world-class Strikers world-class
Grapplers world-class MMA huge events so
they're over here you'll see is over
here
so when it comes to UFC one Championship
once Coca-Cola once Pepsi both massive
everybody else is your surge of the
sport your jasta your freaking Jamba
Juices [__]
they might get a Big Splash in the pan
you know
doesn't matter
it's a two-man race and everybody else
is just picking up pieces mimicking one
championship in UFC
everybody else ain't [__]
yeah the the one will sell for so good
in the production and the different you
know martial arts from Muay Thai to jiu
jitsu to MMA it's not stupid yeah it was
fun so much in the Productions world
class the belt's legit oh you know so it
is like 26 pounds that's what I told Dan
Kelly I'm like you better you're gonna
hit the gym girl you can start wearing
that belt around
um all right so last question is from
Metal Sonic do you think we'll see more
Fighters getting knocked out trying to
trying and failing to use the Philly
shell due to Strickland's recent success
no his Style's so unique No No One's
Gonna Be able to mimic that that's a
very very very unique style and that's
also not a style that you can really
mimic it that's from years and years of
sparring Non-Stop and being Elusive and
that it's like you can take some things
away from Izzy when you watch him or
Robert Whittaker or Wonder Boy or Ian
Gary and can see how he can get there
with Strickland it's such a
unconventional Style no coach the next
day I was like all right today we're
working on the Philly shell for UFC
people and get kicked in the [__]
face left and right so no I don't think
it's gonna happen that's a bad idea
as far as fight wise you have a big
fight card one Championship doing the
damn thing again you got your main card
on Amazon Prime our boy Mikey mushumeshi
going at it again submission grappling
against the legend Aoki
you guys know how I feel about Mikey
mushroom actually doing the goddamn
thing uh you also got some big old
fights on there as well you got the
featherweight kickboxing uh say his name
chin so I because I keep messing it up
hit it talk about
yeah he's a freaking badass yeah super
badass the Dude Looks like he's doing
computer programming while kicking in
the face there's no there's no grimacing
there's no expression he is a straight
up Savage then he got Tali
Conley you guys know tan Lee uh if
you're just kind of American casual he
was on daylight Contender series he was
on The Ultimate Fighter uh he fought in
uh Legacy as well so he's been all over
but then he's also a former world
champion with one championship and he is
a straight up Savage he's fun to watch
man so that's your main event
um yeah Jonathan
dibella Who's the champion in kickboxing
that strawweight fight uh Taiwan Chi who
we also love and they also got Mikey
mushumeshi fighting it's a great card
I'm telling you man you gotta get on
this one Championship train if you like
mixed martial arts if you like martial
arts and General they're doing the damn
thing all right and starts uh that's
October 6. Friday 8pm Eastern 8 P.M
Eastern so it's five o'clock here enjoy
that it's on Amazon Prime you don't want
Championship Amazon go together like
peanut butter and jelly get you some
they have a fight night UFC fight night
um Grant Dawson I think what's this kid
won nine in a row so how to draw one in
a row against Bobby green I assume he's
the favorite favorite fight on the card
there's two of them Alex Morano and
Joaquin Buckley's phenomenal and then
Drew Dober Ricky Glenn is a great fight
Alex Hernandez on there uh Carolina's on
there
uh you get a decent fight night but
Grant Dawson if you haven't checked him
out make sure you do he is a straight
Savage Bob Green's always fun uh Joe
Pfeiffer is a monster I love that fight
that's a great card
Joe Pfeiffer Abdul uh Alex Morano Moreno
Joaquin Buckley Drew Dober Ricky Glenn
Phillip lens cute alibra Alex Hernandez
it's a great Fight Night and the former
stripper Vanessa Demopolis the one that
always jumps on Joe Rogan
shout out to her she started off she's
cool
yep that's pretty much it though all
right kids that's it next up for me I'll
be doing sex around La then I'm in
dubeak Iowa Dubuque Dubuque Iowa one
show Friday 7 P.M one show Saturday 7
P.M that's October 13th and 14th I'm in
Niagara Falls New York November 4th and
5th that's at a casino in Niagara Falls
New York November 5th and 4th so that's
a Friday Saturday one show each night
those are almost sold out so make sure
you get your tickets so it's my fans Not
the casino fans now I'm Chicago December
8th and 9th two shows Friday two shows
Saturday I'll get a bunch of other dates
coming up uh it's the keep on trucking
tour coming straight to you son we have
a bunch of dope uh
Auto content with my truck and a bunch
of other stuff going on stay tuned for
that with the with the transformation to
the TRX demon with Overkill that's all
coming out I'll be posting my Instagram
we'll have a bunch more news as regards
to all the truck stuff and tuning and
all that okay kids love you enjoy one
championship this Friday on Amazon Prime
be nice to each other I'm out